la franja de gaza vive una situación
límite los casos de coronavirus se han
multiplicado en las últimas semanas
hasta por 20 veces y las autoridades
palestinas se han visto obligadas a
decretar confinamientos a la población
un cierre que acentúa la crisis
alimentaria y humanitaria que ya vive
este enclave que cuenta con un 75% de
población pobre y extremadamente pobre
vamos si la pesca sigue detenida a morir
de hambre nadie nos está ayudando les
digo que moriré de hambre
no soy un empleado del gobierno y no
tengo un salario mensual
si tuviera salario 500 shekels al mes y
quedaría en casa no un año sino 10.000
años pero con esta situación si el mar
permanece cerrado no moriré de
coronavirus moriré de hambre
a esto hay que sumarle el bloqueo que
sufre por parte de israel desde hace más
de 13 años que lejos de relajarse se ha
endurecido desde mediados de agosto
israel ha realizado varios ataques
contra hamas en gaza luego de que fuesen
lanzados globos explosivos a su
territorio desde la franja
ante la situación las autoridades piden
una respuesta internacional la franja de
gaza ha estado experimentando
condiciones humanitarias catastróficas
debido al asedio durante más de 13 años
ahora el coronavirus ha entrado en la
sociedad y se debe exigir a las
instituciones internacionales que tome
la iniciativa inmediata para ayudar a la
población de la franja de gaza- hacer
frente a este asedio y a esta pandemia
aunque los territorios palestinos no
fueron muy golpeados durante la primera
ola de la pandemia ahora sí que están
sufriendo directamente las consecuencias
del virus una crisis sanitaria que se ve
agravada por los casi nulos recursos de
los que dispone el enclave a todos los
niveles